c'est lors du journal de l'afrique
seraient les bienvenues sur france 24 à
la une ce soir ce nouvel effondrement
d'immeuble à abidjan en côte d'ivoire ça
s'est passé dans la commune d'abobo un
enfant est mort et trois autres
personnes ont été blessées il y a
quelques semaines deux immeubles
s'étaient écroulés causant la mort de 13
personnes nous serons abidjan dans ce
journal ces combats qui ont opposé ce
lundi l'armée congolaise rebelles du
groupe m23 dans le nord kivu en
république démocratique du congo ce
groupe armé qui avait rendu les armes en
2013 affirme se défendre contre les
provocations de l'armée congolaise une
armée qui accuse de son côté le rwanda
de soutenir les milices la milice les
détails dans ce journal
le sénégal retient son souffle à moins
de 24 heures du match retour contre
l'egypte pour une qualification à la
coupe du monde de football les
coéquipiers de sadio manet avaient raté
leur match aller les enjeux l'enjeu
était énorme nous serons à dakar à la
fin de ce journal
ça s'est passé dans la commune d'abobo à
abidjan un immeuble en construction
s'est effondré causant la mort d'un
enfant depuis fin février c'est le
troisième immeuble qui s'effondre au
total 14 personnes sont décédées ces
effondrements beaucoup choqué la
population et le phénomène inquiète la
correspondance et abidjan de l'anam
ferdjani avec samuel bernard
c'est en réalité l'un des pans de mur
d'un immeuble en construction au stade
d'élévation qui s'est écroulé sur une
habitation voisine les circonstances
restent les mêmes que lors d'incidents
précédents c'est vraisemblablement un
défaut de construction qui est en cause
ici ainsi que la négligence du
propriétaire et chez les habitants du
quartier désert où ce drame s'est
produit le choc et l'indignation ont
pris le dessus et le mot n'avait pas les
photos parce que'elle pas de poté qui
tenait les murs donc pourquoi cette
tombe et le que dumas faire croire
qu'ils allaient venir réparer ça mais ça
n'a pas été fait parce que les
constructions étaient des travaux ont
été stoppés plus d'événements quelques
mois jusqu'aujourd'hui
le béton est tombé sa voiture toute la
famille y compris madame et là des
enfants est nécessaire pour moi parce
que la junte et a passé maître mais
c'est impossible il n'ya pas de suivi
psy mais cette position fait son travail
la moitié ça c'est pas un passé pas à
cause cette critique d'un gouvernement
passif face à une épidémie de
constructions anarchiques et ne
répondant pas aux normes c'était déjà
fait entendre lors des derniers
d'effondrement à abidjan remontant au 27
février et 7 mars dernier en tout treize
personnes sont décédées dans ces
effondrements de son côté le ministère
de la construction a annoncé avoir
sanctionné les responsables
administratifs ayant laissé poursuivre
les travaux sans autorisation préalable
est mise en place une brigade de
contrôle mixte tout en appelant à la
responsabilité de chacun on estime que
l'absence de permis de construire
concerne 80 % des constructions à
abidjan
dans l'est de la république démocratique
du congo des combats opposant lundi
l'armée congolaise rebelles du groupe m
23 dans la province du nord-kivu de
nombreux villageois ont dû fuir vers
l'ouganda voisin ce groupe armé qui
avait rendu les armes en 2013 a repris
les attaques contre l'armée congolaise
il y a quelques mois les mini siens
affirme qu'il se défende et qu'ils sont
la cible de provocation de l'armée la
correspondance à kinshasa de juliette du
bois
selon l'armée congolaise deux de leurs
positions ont été attaquées dans la nuit
de dimanche à lundi par le groupe armé
m23 à changzhou et julio ni dans le
territoire de rutshuru la société civile
signal depuis lundi matin de nombreux
mouvements de populations qui fuient les
combats dans la zone ils se rendent
principalement vers la ville de rutshuru
et vers l'ouganda voisin pour rappel le
m23 est un groupe armé principalement
composée de tutsis congolais qui était
soutenu par le rwanda et l'ouganda ils
ont marqué les esprits en occupant la
ville de goma en 2012 avant d'être
vaincus l'année suivante par l'armée
congolaise et les casques bleus après
avoir rendu les armes le groupe s'est
replié en ouganda et au rwanda mais
depuis novembre dernier il est à nouveau
très actif on dénombre au moins 11
affrontements avec l'armée congolaise
selon pierre boisse les spécialistes des
groupes armés dans la région l'une des
raisons de ce retour est le problème de
ré version des anciens combattants il ya
eu des accords notamment la déclaration
de nairobi qui devait permettre à ce
qu'il revienne
ou se réinsérer dans la société
congolaise
mais ces accords là on n'a jamais été
vraiment respectée on n'est jamais
vraiment aller au bout de ce processus
est alors on peut penser qu est ce qui
se passe depuis depuis novembre indique
qu' ils essayent de faire pression sur
le gouvernement congolais pour obtenir
ce qu'ils estiment être être leurs
droits ou les promesses en tout cas que
l'armée avait affirmé la semaine
dernière avoir détruit l'état major du
m23 dans le territoire de rutshuru dans
un communiqué publié ce week end le
groupe armé déplore que ces opérations
signe selon eux je cite d'une volonté
d'en découdre
et puis sachez que l'armée congolaise
affirmé ce lundi que l' attaque du m23 a
été soutenue par les forces de défense
rwandaises kinshasa annonce également
avoir arrêté deux militaires rwandais la
réaction des autorités guinéennes aux
menaces de sanctions de la cedeao au
cours de son sommet extraordinaire
vendredi dernier l'organisation ouest
africaine a donné jusqu'au 25 avril à la
guinée pour présenter un calendrier
électoral acceptable un avertissement
que la guinée considère comme une
ingérence dans les affaires internes
écouter ousmane goy gaoual diallo porte
parole du gouvernement au micro de notre
correspondant manif diakité ce n'est pas
sur le couple du diktat que mais on fait
les progrès démocratiques et les progrès
dans un site génère pour notre sous
région je pense qu'il faut tenir compte
des prérogatives limitées de chaque pays
et de comprendre le contexte comprendre
la situation d'apprécier les progrès et
d'être là en tant que conseils pour
aider les pays à dépasser les
contradictions mais si on se comporte
comme
des gens qui doivent donner des
injonctions
cela complique un peu les rapports et
les mises en oeuvre des recommandations
qui peuvent arriver je pense que la
cédéao va tous aller coûte que pour
l'ict et des injonctions de temps mieux
qu'elle ne sait pas toujours distingué
dans la prise de position forte quand
les populations étaient menacés
formé il ya à peine trois mois le parti
du leader de l'opposition zimbabwéenne
nelson chamisa a remporté 19 des 28
sièges de députés 75 sièges dans les 122
municipalité il dit avoir bon espoir que
son parti principal adversaire du parti
au pouvoir zanu pf remporte les
élections générales l'an prochain les
détails avec notre correspondant dans la
région caroline dieu mais
c'est une victoire éclair pour le
nouveau parti d'opposition au zimbabwe
la coalition des citoyens pour le
changement qui était un mouvement qui a
été formé et il y à peine trois mois par
nelson chamisa a raflé 19 des 28 sièges
qui étaient à pourvoir au parlement
le reste a été emporté par le parti au
pouvoir le zanu pf demerson mnangagwa
rien pour le mdc le parti historique
d'opposition qui avait scissionner à la
mort de son leader morgan tsvangiraï
donc recomposition du paysage politique
nelson chamisa et l'homme fort de
l'opposition au zimbabwe et il est
plutôt fier car ces élections n'ont pas
été faciles
on a perdu un de nos membres et rien n'a
été fait et on sait pas qui l'a tué six
ou sept meetings interrompt la police a
interdit cette manifestation et dans les
zones rurales des actes d'intimidation
de violence et de terreur
c'était des élections partielles le
parti au pouvoir conserve la majorité au
parlement il conserve aussi ses fiefs
dans les zones rurales et ses
responsables expliquent qu'ils ont aussi
fait des progrès dans les villes du sud
est cool c'est un très bon signe on
pense que ça pourrait même être un
tournant
c'est notre message qui atteint mieux
les zones urbaines le message
d'ouverture économique du pays du
président menem gallois résonne dans les
centres urbains
c'est pour cela qu'on a gagné aussi
certains siègent dans les conseils
municipaux des visites
le paysage politique zimbabwe a changé
et les dés sont jetés pour les élections
générales de 2023 en tunisie le
parlement a annoncé lundi la tenue d'une
séance plénière mercredi défiant ainsi
le président kaïs aed qui a suspendu la
chambre et s'est arrogé les pleins
pouvoirs en juillet dernier la tenue de
cette séance a été décidée par le bureau
de l'assemblée des représentants du
peuple une instance qui regroupe la
présidence du parlement et des
représentants des partis qui y siéger
cette bonne nouvelle pour le secteur
touristique en tunisie le bad les
bateaux de croisières sont de retour
dans le pays une première depuis 2000 19
après deux saison touristique
désastreuse les autorités espèrent que
le nombre de visiteurs et les dépenses
atteindront à 60% du niveau de 2010 neuf
fois ci me cornette
ils sont de retour pour la première fois
depuis 2000 19 un bateau de croisière
remplis de touristes a accosté dans un
port tunisien un soulagement pour les
autorités du pays plus de 700 touristes
britanniques allemands italiens et
espagnols sont arrivés à tunis dans ce
bouquet de jasmin chapeau orné de
parures traditionnels
le ministère du tourisme a sorti le
grand jeu pour accueillir ses visiteurs
tant attendu
c'est le début de ce que les autorités
espèrent être une bonne saison
touristique le pays attend plus de 40
bateaux tels que celui ci cette année à
ouattara relève passées à balayer badri
ci a annoncé
l'industrie du tourisme espèrent
retrouver des niveaux proches des 60% de
2019 la meilleure année depuis la
révolution tunisienne ou huit ans plus
tôt au moment de débarquer les passagers
avaient hâte de débuter leur séjour
[Musique]
le tourisme est un secteur clé de
l'économie tunisienne il représente 14 %
du pib et fait vivre un sixième de la
population du pays
à ce que ce culte et d'afrique centrale
datant du 19e siècle a été adjugé pour
plus de 4 millions d'euros lors d'une
vente aux enchères ce samedi à paris une
vente qui a été perturbée par des
activistes gabonais qui réclame sa
restitution précise de le renverser cher
en pleine audience un homme interrompt
les enchères et s'emporte contre une
vente qui jugent illégitime
l'objet en question un rarissime masques
traditionnels gabonais datant du 19ème
siècle porté par les membres de la
société secrète ighil des justiciers
chargé notamment de traquer les sorciers
celui ci a été acquis dans des
conditions inconnues par le gouverneur
colonial rené victor fournier avant
d'être retrouvé dans un grenier est mis
en vente par ses descendants les
activistes gabonais qui ont interrompu
les enchères dénonce un bien coloniale
et mal acquis qui doit être restitué à
son pays d'origine le gouverneur fourni
en ce temps là en 1917 qui est passé dit
ont collecté ce bien en principe le
terme idéal c'est volés dérobés arraché
pillés
et qui nous ne pouvons pas accepter que
ce bien soit là ici exposé alors qu'il a
été volé l'association des gabonais de
montpellier dit avoir lancé une
procédure légale pour récupérer le
masque en attendant celui ci a été vendu
à un collectionneur anonyme pour une
somme de 4,2 millions d'euros près de
dix fois son estimation initiale
mais tout nouveau champion d'afrique
seront ils là présent à la prochaine
coupe du monde de football réponse ce
mardi à dakar après un match qui
s'annonce serré après sa défaite au
match aller au caire vendredi dernier le
sénégal est dans l'obligation de réagir
au risque d'être éliminé la
correspondance est là car le sahara fait
la tension monte ici au sénégal à
quelques heures de cette rencontre
capitale les lions de la teranga doivent
absolument remporter cette rencontre
contre l'egypte avec au moins deux buts
d'écart après leur défaite au caire en
tout cas s'ils veulent se qualifier pour
ce mondial et les sénégalais sont comme
un seul homme derrière leur équipe
encore auréolés de leur titre de
champion d'afrique ils ne veulent
absolument pas rater le coche je vous
propose d'écouter ces réactions
recueillies dans les rues de dakar on
espère tous que le sénégal va gagner
voilà et le sénégal va rentrer une fois
de plus encore dans l'histoire du
football résultat ils sont forts
défensivement sont tellement forts mais
le sénégal aussi à des armes offensives
notamment sa de manège militaire ils
sont tellement rapides 2 je pense que le
sénégal et la semafo reçu ce matin
le match va se tenir dans le tout
nouveau stade abdoulaye wade de
diamniadio un match qui va se jouer à
guichet fermé puisqu'il est pratiquement
impossible désormais de se procurer un
billet pour cette rencontre à moins de
l'acheter au marché noir a parfois dix
fois sa valeur initiale
voilà si vous n'avez pas pu vous
procurer un billet vous pourrez toujours
suivre les résultats sur france 24 et on
en reparlera également dans le journal
de l'afrique c'est la fin de cette
édition rester avec nous dans quelques
instants la suite de paris direct avec
anthony saint léger
[Musique]